Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to let's go to
win from Indiana. Win you're on the air. Is win
short for something?
Speaker 3:
I but can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 6: OK. When is not sure from from for
anything. I'm actually originally from Thailand
but I moved to Indiana a couple of months ago.
Speaker 1: How is that?
Speaker 6: It's different. I'm just
here for college. OK, this is different.
All right. The a question in regards to demand
versus supply economics. Sure. I was talking
to my uncle, who is from Las Vegas, and he sort of
agreed with the idea of demand economics and that,
you know, demand drives businesses and whatnot.
But he used the example of Las Vegas saying that
before Vegas was in the middle of
the desert, but because of like
low regulation, lower taxes, it encourages
businesses to open up casinos and therefore,
you know, there was more business activity.
So I was just curious, what are your
what are your thoughts on that argument?
Speaker 1: I see. So let me see if I want
to make sure I understand the argument. It sounds
like you're saying your uncle generally believes
that demand is what drives businesses to open.
There's demand for a product or service. So
that's an opportunity for a business to enter.
But with Vegas, his argument is in Vegas. What
created all of these casinos and hotels and all
that stuff is that there was low regulation,
so it was attractive rather than
driven. Am I hearing that correctly?
Yes, I think the counterpoint would be and I
think it's a it's a it's a natural one in a sense.
There was already pent up demand for what Vegas
initially offered, it was demand from all over the
United States. There was already, even if people
did not necessarily know, what we're looking for
is a gaming paradise in the desert or whatever,
you had a population that was big enough with
diverse enough interests that there was a pent
up demand. And so that's why business people,
when they said, hey, what about a casino?
Vegas is a good place. The low regulation
may have been why they chose Vegas, but the demand
generally for a gaming industry was already there.
Speaker 6: I see. OK, so so do you think it
depends on particular services or products that
supply or demand is going to be the
determining factor? Do you think know there
are some cases that supply may drive businesses?
Speaker 1: Yeah, so so listen, here's the thing.
This is a this is a quite an involved topic.
There are products and services that benefit,
for example, from network effects where
actually more supply increases the perceived
value of the product or service and supply can
actually drive demand. There are luxury goods
where you actually might sometimes see supply and
demand interact in different ways than a typical
supply and demand curve. There's really no one
answer to this. And one can, generally speaking,
understand that demand drives hiring while still
realizing that there are other types of situations
that we have to sort of account for separately.
Speaker 6: Right. I see what that was. That
was great. Yeah, the idea of pent up demand. I
didn't think of that. Awesome. Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: My. And last thing. Yeah. The low
regulation alone, if there was no pent up
demand for hotels and casinos, you can go whether
there's low or high regulation and build a hotel
and casino. If nobody wants to be in a casino,
it's not going to matter that the regulation
was low. You understand what I'm saying?
Speaker 6: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: All right. Wynn, thank you. I
appreciate the call. Thank you. All right.
Wynn from Thailand now in Indiana. Let's take
a quick break. Don't hang up if you're holding,
because we're going to get right back to a
few more calls right after this short break.